So when I dunk it in you'll see like I'll just try to make minimal splashes Artists and curator Luccaza Brampman for Esemo. Do you want to put on some gloves and put things in? Yeah We're in her backyard in Oakland making an indigo bath Which is to say we are making a natural blue dye using powder from the indigo plant and it's kind of complicated This is actually our second time trying to make indigo, because the first time we didn't get the ratio rate, it's tricky. Pig too.
所以当我把它浸进去的时候，你会看到，我会尽量少溅出水花。艺术家兼策展人卢卡萨·布兰普曼（Luccaza Brampman）为Esemo工作。你想戴上手套把东西放进去吗？好啊。我们在她位于奥克兰的后院里制作靛蓝染液，也就是说，我们正在用靛蓝植物的粉末制作天然蓝色染料，这其实挺复杂的。这其实是我们第二次尝试制作靛蓝，因为第一次我们没掌握好比例，这很棘手。还有猪。
Yes, I have better help in it this time. Lucasa begins by stirring the indigo powder and the other ingredients together in this vat of hot water. Moving it very slowly because we don't want the oxygen to get into the bath. You have to stir it kind of lovingly and slowly. And then, if you actually do it right and all goes according to plan, it's amazing.
是的，这次我有更好的帮手。卢卡萨首先将靛蓝粉末和其他配料一起在这大缸热水里搅拌。动作要非常慢，因为我们不想让氧气进入染液中。你必须带着喜爱和缓慢的心态去搅拌它。然后，如果你真的做对了，一切按计划进行，那真是太神奇了。
Yay! You and what I want it to do. The indigo mixture seems to come alive in the water. It starts fizzing and glistening as you stir it. It's so psychedelic, like these metallic, shimmery bubbly chunks are swirling around in water. It's like we were mixing a cauldron of deep swirling purple potion.
耶！你和我希望它做到的那样。靛蓝混合物似乎在水中活了过来。当你搅拌它时，它开始起泡并闪闪发光。这太迷幻了，就像这些金属质感的、闪闪发光的泡沫块在水中旋转。就像我们在混合一锅深邃旋转的紫色药水。
And then when we dunked in some white t-shirts, they came out deep green. And then as we let the shirts dry in the sun, patches of blue gradually emerge, and slowly spread over the cloth. Like we had conjured it. It's pretty cool. Yeah, I mean, I think it is really like a magical process.
然后，当我们把几件白T恤浸进去时，它们变成了深绿色。接着，当我们让衬衫在阳光下晾干时，蓝色的斑块逐渐显现出来，并慢慢在布料上蔓延开来。就像是我们凭空变出来的一样。这真的很酷。是的，我的意思是，我觉得这真的是一个神奇的过程。
It's also just like makes a really beautiful color. I feel like who doesn't like indigo blue? Nobody. Nobody doesn't like indigo blue. Or at least I can't imagine anyone hating it. It's so ubiquitous. It'll be like someone hating water. Indigo is everywhere.
它也只是能造出一种非常美丽的颜色。我觉得谁会不喜欢靛蓝呢？没有人。没有人不喜欢靛蓝。或者至少我想象不出有人会讨厌它。它是如此无处不在。这就好比有人讨厌水一样。靛蓝无处不在。
Because indigo is what put the blue in blue jeans. Articles of interest, a show about what we wear. And so maybe the idea is about clothes. You can attach ideas about clothes. An idea of home to a piece of cloth. Either a glass or a blanket or a blanket. Any fork and wear clothes. But if you ain't got the attitude and style to carry it off, Man, you're just the closed walls.
因为靛蓝是赋予牛仔裤蓝色的功臣。《感兴趣的物件》（Articles of Interest），一档关于我们穿什么的节目。所以也许这个想法是关于衣服的。你可以把关于衣服的想法寄托于此。把家的概念寄托在一块布上。不管是玻璃、毯子还是毯子。任何叉子都可以穿衣服。但如果你没有驾驭它的态度和风格，天哪，你不过是个行尸走肉。
What's great about Blue Jeans, we like to say that we pioneered them, and we claim being the inventor of them. This is Tracy Panic, the corporate historian at Levi Strousing Company. They touch on the roots of the blue collar workers. They became a canvas for self-expression in the 1960s, so in many ways they hit on key cultural moments that go across our society. This is the difference between denim and jeans. Denim is a fabric that can be used in
蓝色牛仔裤最棒的地方在于，我们喜欢说是由我们开创的，并且我们声称自己是它们的发明者。这是特蕾西·帕尼克（Tracy Panek），李维斯公司（Levi Strauss & Company）的企业历史学家。它们触及了蓝领工人的根基。在20世纪60年代，它们成为了自我表达的画布，所以在许多方面，它们击中了跨越我们社会的关键文化时刻。这就是丹宁布和牛仔裤的区别。丹宁是一种可以用于
jacket shirt, dresses, tablecloths, a poultry. You name it. Blue jeans are a very specific kind of pants. And they have a couple hallmarks. For the most part, they are blue and they are worn in. They basically look like this. This that you're looking at is the oldest pair of blue jeans in the world. It dates to about 1879. And this is the blueprint for all blue jeans today. The world's oldest pair of blue jeans. They looked classic, meaning they really don't look very different from the kinds of jeans
夹克、衬衫、连衣裙、桌布、家具面料的布料。应有尽有。蓝色牛仔裤是一种非常特定的裤子。它们有几个标志。在大多数情况下，它们是蓝色的，并且是穿旧了的。它们基本上长这样。你现在看到的这个是世界上最古老的蓝色牛仔裤。它可追溯到大约1879年。这就是当今所有蓝色牛仔裤的蓝图。世界上最古老的蓝色牛仔裤。它们看起来很经典，这意味着它们看起来确实跟你在如今的旧货店里
you'd find in a thrift store today. They'd held up well. Yes, they were patched in a little stained, but if I wanted to, I could have totally put them on right there and walked out of the archive wearing them. And the security guard wouldn't have even noticed because they're still just jeans. The differences are subtle. This one only has one pocket in the back. We didn't add the second pocket onto the back until 1901. And here's the really cool thing about old blue jeans.
能找到的牛仔裤没有太大区别。它们保存得很好。是的，它们被打上了补丁，还有点污渍，但如果我想的话，我完全可以当场穿上它们，然后穿着它们走出档案馆。而且保安甚至都不会注意到，因为它们依然只是牛仔裤。细微之处在于。这条裤子后面只有个口袋。直到1901年，我们才在后面加了第二个口袋。关于旧蓝色牛仔裤，最酷的地方在于。
With most of our clothes, we try to keep them pretty pristine and avoid spills and rips and tears. But denim is so hard wearing and hard working. It just kind of amasses more and more signs of wear. So you can dissect a pair of old jeans like an archeologist. You can actually see how someone walked or sat. You'll see all of this wear, this honey combing as we call it. That's simply wear and tear from the people, the men who were wearing it.
对于我们大多数衣服，我们都尽量保持它们崭新，避免溅上污渍、撕裂和破洞。但丹宁布非常耐磨、经久耐用。它只是会不断积聚越来越多的磨损痕迹。所以你可以像考古学家一样剖析一条旧牛仔裤。你实际上可以看出一个人是怎么走路或坐着的。你会看到所有这些磨损，我们称之为猫须纹的纹理。这纯粹是穿戴它的人——那些穿着它的男人们留下的磨损。
And we think that there were as many as three men who wore this particular pant. You can tell by looking at the impressions on the knees. The knee marks go up and down in several places because they are in several locations. We know that several people wore them. And that was common with jeans. They'd get passed around. They were sturdy enough that you could do that, which is kind of romantic, right? Because this is still how we like to think of our blue jeans today. Broken in, durable, something to be worn and re-worn and passed around just like these original genes.
我们认为这条特定的裤子有多达三个男人穿过。你可以通过观察膝盖上的压痕看出来。膝盖的印记在好几个地方上下延伸，因为它们出现在多个位置。我们知道有几个人穿过它们。这在牛仔裤中很常见。它们会被转手。它们足够结实，所以你能这么做，这某种程度上很浪漫，对吧？因为今天我们依然这样看待我们的蓝色牛仔裤。被穿旧了的、耐用的、可以被反复穿着、反复转手的东西，就像这些最初的牛仔裤一样。
But the genes you and I wear today may look like those original Levi's, how they may even say Levi's on them. But they are not the same kind of pants. In between 1879 and today, pretty much everything that makes blue jeans blue jeans from how they're made to what they're made of to where they end up has changed. Because blue jeans reveal our wear patterns, our values. They show the movements we make over and over again. They show our true color. They show our true color. So denim was around before Levi Strauss.
但你和我今天穿的牛仔裤可能看起来像最初的李维斯，它们甚至可能上面写着“李维斯”。但它们不是同一种裤子。在1879年到今天之间，几乎所有让蓝色牛仔裤成为蓝色牛仔裤的东西——从它们的制作方式、制作材料到它们的最终去向——都改变了。因为蓝色牛仔裤展现了我们的穿着习惯、我们的价值观。它们展示了我们一遍又一遍做出的动作。它们展现了我们的本色。它们展现了我们的本色。所以早在李维斯·施特劳斯之前，丹宁布就存在了。
And blue denim trousers were around before Levi Strauss. But here is what Levi Strauss did that made the blue gene. He patented the rivets on the pockets. The innovation of the rivets is that you could take a little tiny piece of metal, add them to the pockets, and they became much stronger. So if you're putting your hands in your pockets, they're not going to tear. The rivets were the big selling point, not necessarily the denim. And when they used denim, it wasn't always necessarily blue.
在李维斯·施特劳斯之前，蓝色丹宁裤就已经存在了。但这就是李维斯·施特劳斯所做的事情，它造就了蓝色牛仔裤。他为口袋上的铆钉申请了专利。铆钉的创新在于，你可以拿一小块金属，把它们加到口袋上，它们就会变得结实得多。所以如果你把手放进口袋里，它们就不会撕裂。铆钉是最大的卖点，不一定是因为丹宁布。而且当他们使用丹宁布时，它并不一定总是蓝色的。
It doesn't have to be. Blue is just tradition. Denim can be any color. Lin Downey is a biographer of Levi Strauss and the former Levi's corporate historian before Tracy. Over the years, the company did make blue and gold denim products. I think there was even a red denim, like red and white denim.
它不一定非得是蓝色的。蓝色只是传统。丹宁布可以是任何颜色。林·道尼（Lin Downey）是李维斯·施特劳斯（Levi Strauss）的传记作家，也是特蕾西之前的李维斯公司前企业历史学家。多年来，该公司确实生产过蓝色和金色的丹宁产品。我想甚至还有红色的丹宁，比如红白相间的丹宁。
But it was indigo, indigo blue died thread. That was easiest. That seemed to last the longest and people just gravitate toward it. It's hard to explain why humans are so attracted to Indigo. Historically, the die had massive power. Indigo used to be very rare and expensive, especially since that process of dying is so special and magical. Blue was a symbol of status and or wealth all over the world. Indigo has its roots in India, hence its name,
但正是靛蓝，用靛蓝染色的纱线。那是轻而易举的事。那似乎持续时间最长，人们自然而然地被它吸引。很难解释为什么人类对靛蓝如此着迷。历史上，这种染料有着巨大的力量。靛蓝曾经非常稀有且昂贵，尤其是因为这种染色过程如此特殊和神奇。在世界各地，蓝色是地位和/或财富的象征。靛蓝的根源在印度，因此得名，
and variants grow in Vietnam, in West Africa, and the tropics, anywhere where it's humid. It needs humidity, you know, heat and humidity. The same conditions as rice. So Indigo was also able to thrive in South Carolina. Indigo had first been cultivated in the United States in the 1740s by a woman, oh by the way, Eliza Pinkney. She was really a girl.
其变种生长在越南、西非和热带地区，任何潮湿的地方。它需要湿度，你知道的，热量和湿度。与水稻相同的条件。所以靛蓝也能在南卡罗来纳州蓬勃生长。靛蓝最早于18世纪40年代在美国由一位女性培育，哦，顺便说一句，她叫伊丽莎白·平克尼（Eliza Pinkney）。她其实还是个女孩。
She was 16 years old. Born in Antiga, and her family then had plantations in South Carolina, and she and her family moved there. And her father had sent her some indigo seeds from the Caribbean, and she thought, let's try this. She was able to cultivate enough indigo to make it a cash crop.
她当时16岁。出生于安提瓜，她的家人随后在南卡罗来纳州拥有种植园，她和家人搬到了那里。她的父亲从加勒比海寄给她一些靛蓝种子，她想，让我们试试这个。她成功培育出了足够多的靛蓝，使其成为了一种经济作物。
But when indigo became a cash crop, it became mass-produced. And so that labor-intensive magical process of making indigo was scaled up with slave labor. And I can just imagine the slaves and the women, especially, are stirring these indigo vats as they were processing this die, and their hands were blue. Before the American Revolution, before cotton became king,
但当靛蓝成为经济作物时，它就被大量生产了。因此，这种劳动密集型的、制作靛蓝的神奇过程通过奴隶劳动力扩大了规模。我甚至可以想象，奴隶们，尤其是女性，在加工这种染料时搅拌着这些靛蓝染缸，她们的手都是蓝色的。在独立战争之前，在棉花称王之前，
indigo was the second largest cash crop in the colonies after rice. There were indigo plantations all across the south, and some of them lasted well into the Civil War. Virginia, South Carolina, for sure. This story takes place in Georgia. This is Ann Masai, and she has this amazing story about her grandfather's grandfather, who was born as a slave on an indigo plantation. His name is John, John Henry, and it was very common for them to swaddle the babies in the blue cloth. So when baby John was born, his parents decided to escape, so they wrapped baby John in
靛蓝是殖民地仅次于水稻的第二大经济作物。整个南方到处都是靛蓝种植园，其中一些一直持续到内战时期。弗吉尼亚州、南卡罗来纳州，绝对有。这个故事发生在佐治亚州。这位是安·马萨伊（Ann Masai），她有一个关于她祖父的祖父的惊人故事，他出生于一个靛蓝种植园，是个奴隶。他的名字叫约翰（John），约翰·亨利（John Henry），当时用蓝色布料包裹婴儿是非常普遍的做法。所以当婴儿约翰出生时，他的父母决定逃跑，于是他们用蓝色布料包裹了婴儿约翰。
indigo and headed north. They crept through the underbrush, creeping their way up. About an hour after they set out They heard dogs barking in the distance and the screaming of the voices that they recognized was the overseer So they ran into the brush. They found a place to hide they secreted themselves and baby John started to whip her and fuss somebody came over and It was investigating this noise. It was the overseer. He and was investigating this noise. It was the overseer. He looked down just as the moon came out
靛蓝并向北进发。他们蹑手蹑脚地穿过灌木丛，一路往上爬。出发大约一个小时后，他们听到远处有狗在叫，还有他们认出是监工的声音的尖叫声。于是他们跑进灌木丛。他们找到了一个藏身之处，把自己藏了起来，婴儿约翰开始哭闹和烦躁。有人走过来，正在调查这个声音。是监工。他正调查这个声音。是监工。月亮刚一出来，他就向下看去，
and the baby John jumped him, screamed out and suddenly the overseer ran away like, well, well, get out, get out. Yankees are here, the Yankees are here, the blues are here. The blues of the Union Army's uniforms. Get out, get out, the blues are here. He saw baby John swaddled in the blue cloth,
婴儿约翰扑向他，大声尖叫，突然监工逃跑了，仿佛在说，快走，快走。北方佬来了，北方佬来了，蓝军来了。北方佬指联邦军队的制服。快走，快走，蓝军来了。他看到婴儿约翰被包裹在蓝色布料中，
the indigo cloth, and the overseer thought that that was a Yankee in his blue cloth hiding, and they're going to be am bushing this group, and they got out. This story that Anne has is a rare one passed from generation to generation. And hearing about an indigo plantation nestled in the land of cotton plantations presents a sad, ready-made symbolism.
靛蓝布料，监工以为那是穿着蓝色布料藏起来的北方佬，他们打算伏击这群人，于是他们逃跑了。安拥有的这个故事是一个罕见的、代代相传的故事。听到一个坐落在棉花种植园土地上的靛蓝种植园，呈现出一种悲伤的、现成的象征意义。
Because cotton and indigo go really well together. Cotton loves indigo. The cotton really loved soaking up that indigo. And this, according to Lynn Downey, is part of why genes are blue. Not only was indigo a beautiful color that humans have always been attracted to, it was the color that could cling to fabric best. And it was a color that was very present
因为棉花和靛蓝非常相配。棉花喜欢靛蓝。棉花真的很喜欢吸收那种靛蓝。据林·道尼（Lynn Downey）说，这也是为什么牛仔裤是蓝色的部分原因。靛蓝不仅是人类一直以来都为之着迷的美丽颜色，它还是最能附着在布料上的颜色。而且它是一种在美国非常普遍的颜色，
in the United States, and it was relatively easy to procure. By the time that Levi was buying denim, which is the 1860s, there was a system in place for textile manufacturers to get their indigo. And this is where our idea of blue jeans kind of got frozen in time, made to last forever,
而且相对容易获得。到李维斯购买丹宁布的时候，也就是19世纪60年代，纺织制造商已经有了一套获取靛蓝的系统。这就是我们的蓝色牛仔裤概念被时间定格的地方，注定要永远存在，
100% cotton, 100% indigo. And are jeans still made with actual natural indigo? Not really big lines of them, no. Indigo's magic concoction is too fickle and expensive and complicated for a massive industrial scale. Most denim now is synthetic indigo, but synthetic indigo is not without its own kind of cruelty. It's often made with petroleum mixed with heavy metals and other chemicals. A lot of chemicals there is used in processing of this fabric,
100%纯棉，100%靛蓝。那么现在的牛仔裤仍然是用真正的天然靛蓝制作的吗？大规模生产的并不是，没有。对于庞大的工业规模来说，靛蓝的神奇配方太善变、太昂贵、太复杂了。现在的大多数丹宁布都是合成靛蓝，但合成靛蓝也并非没有它自己的一种残酷性。它通常是由石油与重金属和其他化学品混合制成的。在加工这种面料的过程中使用了大量的化学物质，
hazardous to humans. This is Ada Kong, the toxic manager at Greenpeace East Asia. She says the textile industry discharges the third most waste water in China. And this runoff chemical water gets disposed of in the rivers and basically poisons them. The thing is that the waters might be used for the local farmers for irrigation. They might have problem growing dig crops. Lots of dye colors have harmful chemicals. It's not just synthetic indigo.
对人类有害。这位是绿色和平组织东亚分部的有毒物质经理孔蔼怡（Ada Kong）。她说，中国的纺织工业排放的废水在全国位居第三。这些随之流失的化学废水被排入河流，基本上毒害了它们。问题是这些水可能会被当地农民用于灌溉。他们在种植庄稼时可能会遇到问题。许多染料颜色都含有有害化学物质。不仅仅是合成靛蓝。
But here is the other thing that makes denim especially noteworthy in terms of production. Jeans use up a lot of water. They're actually all washed in China multiple times and all this washing wastewater is charged to the rivers multiple times. That's the special thing about denim. Yes, we expect jeans to be blue, but we also expect genes to come soft and worn in. No other textile on mass is being purposefully broken down in this way before it even goes on a shelf. This is Emma McClendon, Associate Curator of Costume at the Fashion Institute of Technology. And she says after the genes are dyed, they are washed, and maybe washed again, and maybe washed again.
但还有一件事让丹宁布在生产方面尤为引人注目。牛仔裤消耗大量的水。它们实际上在中国被多次水洗，所有这些水洗废水都被多次排入河流。这就是丹宁布的特殊之处。是的，我们期望牛仔裤是蓝色的，但我们也期望牛仔裤穿起来柔软且有旧感。没有任何其他纺织品在批量生产时，会在上架之前就以这种方式被刻意做旧。这位是艾玛·麦克伦登（Emma McClendon），时装技术学院（Fashion Institute of Technology）服装副策展人。她说，在牛仔裤被染色后，它们会被水洗，也许还会再次水洗，也许还会再次水洗。
They are being broken down, being made softer, and given that touch of white that emerges, the top layer of blue cotton is worn away. To get that worn-in look, manufacturers actually pour bags of rocks into industrial washing machines to pummel the genes while they spin. This is stone washing. Literally washing genes, several cycles after they're made into genes, washing them in giant industrial washers with varying sizes of stones. Pummus, you know, this volcanic stone. Now I know, I know, you might be thinking, no, no, no, I don't wear pre-distressed jeans. I just wear simple, sturdy, well-made jeans
它们正在被破坏、变得更柔软，并呈现出那一抹隐现的白色，蓝色棉花的顶层被磨损掉了。为了获得那种穿旧的外观，制造商实际上会在工业洗衣机里倒入一袋袋的石头，在它们旋转时捶打牛仔裤。这就是石洗。字面意思上的水洗牛仔裤，在它们被做成牛仔裤后的几个循环中，用大小不一的石头在巨大的工业洗衣机里水洗它们。浮石，你知道的，这种火山石。现在我知道，我知道，你可能在想，不，不，不，我可不穿预先做旧的牛仔裤。我只穿简单、结实、做工精良的牛仔裤，
and I hate all those artificial holes all over the place. Well, here's the thing. You probably do wear pre-distressed jeans. If you have bought jeans within the last four decades, they've been processed. When people bring up stonewashing, most people think it's something very 80s, and that's just not the case.
我讨厌所有那些到处都是的人造洞。好吧，事实是这样的。你可能确实穿了预先做旧的牛仔裤。如果你在过去的四十年里买过牛仔裤，它们都经过了处理。当人们提起石洗时，大多数人认为那是很80年代的东西，但事实并非如此。
Every gene on the market today that is not a raw denim gene has been stonewashed. Really? Denim, raw denim is incredibly stiff. Feel this. It's really heavy and stiff. Feel this. It's really heavy. And hard. And hard.
市面上的每一条牛仔裤，只要不是原色牛仔裤，都经过了石洗。真的吗？丹宁布，原色牛仔裤极其硬挺。摸摸这个。它真的很重很硬。摸摸这个。它真的很重。而且很硬。而且很硬。
That's not necessarily something you want to put on your body. This is Ulrich Simpson, a designer and owner of the small independent denim brand Ubi End, short for ubiquitous industries. He is showing me the raw, unprocessed denim fabric, which is very thick and heavy, and it's just a uniform, dark, dark, navy blue. It has no stretch whatsoever. No give. Jeans like that first pair of Levi's from 1879 started off as raw, just like this.
这不一定是你想要穿在身上的东西。这位是乌尔里希·辛普森（Ulrich Simpson），一位设计师兼小型独立丹宁品牌Ubi End（即ubiquitous industries的缩写，意为无处不在的产业）的老板。他正在向我展示原生的、未经处理的丹宁面料，它非常厚实沉重，而且是一种均匀的、深邃的藏青色。它完全没有弹性。没有伸缩空间。像1879年那条最初的李维斯牛仔裤一样，最初都是原生的，就像这样。
All old Jeans did. They only got soft because the men, or the three men who owned them, just like this. All old jeans did. They only got soft because the men, or the three men who owned them, wore them down. A lot of people don't go there. Today, Ulrich is one of the few patient people who actually wear raw, unprocessed denim. I'm sure I've been chafed. But yeah, I mean, it's just part of the process.
所有的旧牛仔裤都是如此。它们之所以变软，只是因为那些男人，或者拥有它们的三个男人，就这样。所有的旧牛仔裤都是如此。它们之所以变软，只是因为那些男人，或者拥有它们的三个男人，把它们穿旧了。很多人不会去经历那个过程。如今，乌尔里希是少数几个有耐心真正穿着原生、未经处理的丹宁布的人之一。我确信我被磨破过皮。但对，我的意思是，这只是过程的一部分。
It's like anyone's breaking in a pair of shoes, anything, yeah. I don't know. It kind of seems a little more extreme than that to me. Breaking in denim means you have to wear these thick, heavy, scratchy jeans for like six months without washing them. If you get something on it, you may be trying to vacuum it or brush it off. And after all that time, after all those many, many weeks of chafing, you finally wash those jeans for the first time. And that first wash will reveal all the marks
就像任何人都在把一双鞋穿合脚一样，任何事情都一样，是的。我不知道。对我来说，这似乎有点比那更极端。驯服丹宁意味着你必须穿着这些又厚、又重、又扎人的牛仔裤大约六个月不能洗。如果上面沾了东西，你可能会试图用吸尘器吸掉或者刷掉。在经历了这一切之后，在经历了许多许多周的摩擦之后，你终于第一次洗了这条牛仔裤。第一次水洗将会显现出所有的痕迹，
you've made, all the crinkles around your hips when you sit, the imprint of your iPhone in your back pocket. And then they will finally have that soft, worn-in feeling that we all associate with denim. But this is so much work. Only real denim heads bother to break in their own jeans. It's the maybe 3% that will actually wait and go through that process to get it to then feel like this. And this is the one that's been artificially processed. Denim Maker's artificially processed genes to break them down for you.
你制造的所有痕迹，你坐下时臀部周围的褶皱，你后口袋里iPhone的印记。然后它们终于会拥有那种我们都与丹宁联系在一起的柔软、穿旧的感觉。但这工作量太大了。只有真正的丹宁狂热者才会费心去驯服他们自己的牛仔裤。大概只有3%的人会真正等待并经历这个过程，让它最终感觉像这样。而这是经过人工处理的。丹宁制造商人工处理牛仔裤，为你将它们做旧。
So that, you know, you don't have to go through the breakdown period to look like that. And stonewashing is one method for this, but there are also manufacturers who will break the genes down by hand. You send it down. People like physical families. They're physically hand-sanding.
这样，你知道的，你就不用经历做旧期就能看起来那样。石洗是其中的一种方法，但也有制造商通过手工来做旧牛仔裤。你把它送过去。人们就像物理家族一样。他们用物理方式进行手工打磨。
They'll hand-sand all of this process with a fine sand paper. Workers will sand paper each individual pair of genes to make them look like they've been worn in, to create marks and fades, even slight ones, so that denim has that authentic, worn-in look and feel of those archetypal 1879 jeans, worn-in by three different men over the course of decades. So, in mass pursuit of this comfort and authenticity, blue jeans have become a completely different garment. The colors are different, they're synthetic
他们会用细砂纸手工打磨整个过程。工人们会用砂纸打磨每一条牛仔裤，让它们看起来像是被穿旧了，从而制造出痕迹和褪色，甚至是轻微的褪色，让丹宁拥有那种1879年原型牛仔裤正宗的、穿旧的外观和触感，那些由三个不同的男人历经数十年穿旧的牛仔裤。因此，为了追求这种舒适感和真实感，蓝色牛仔裤已经变成了一件完全不同的服装。颜色变了，它们含有合成成分
and stretch elements in them. Like what does this even mean? What does it even mean to call something denim? The labor of breaking in and wearing down the jeans has been transferred from the customer to the manufacturer. The blue is not indigo, and the cotton is not exactly cotton. I mean denim has stretch. What do you think stretches? Denim increasingly has synthetic fibers in it. Denim is not cotton anymore.
和弹力成分。这到底意味着什么？把某种东西称为丹宁到底意味着什么？把牛仔裤穿旧和磨损的劳动力已经从顾客转移到了制造商身上。蓝色不是靛蓝，棉花也不完全是棉花。我的意思是丹宁有弹性。你认为什么有弹性？丹宁越来越多地含有合成纤维。丹宁不再是纯棉的了。
Lycra nylon polyester. It goes by many names. But let's call it what it is. It's plastic. This is as much applicable to denim as any other part of the industry. Emma McClendon says we are at an unprecedented phase in clothing history. We've never had so many clothes available with so much plastic in them, and no one knows what these leggings
莱卡、尼龙、聚酯纤维。它有很多名字。但让我们直呼其名吧。它是塑料。这不仅适用于丹宁，也适用于服装行业的任何其他部分。艾玛·麦克伦登（Emma McClendon）说，我们正处于服装历史上前所未有的阶段。我们从来没有拥有过这么多含有如此多塑料的衣服，而且没有人知道这些紧身裤、
and sweat-wicking jackets and super stretchy jeans are going to look like 30 years from now. Plastics don't age well, and we don't see it because we throw it out before we see it at that stage. In the future, our jeans, which we've gone to such great lengths to make appear loved and worn in, will probably not age like those genes in the Levi's archive. This is what people need to realize plastics, sometimes age in such a way that they are attempting to go back to a gas or they want to go back to a liquid. So that means that if you feel your sneaker soul that you've had for a really long time begins to stick to the floor. You should get rid of it because it is what we would call weeping or other terminology. It's going back to its liquid state. It's toxic.
吸湿排汗夹克和超高弹力牛仔裤在30年后的样子会是怎样的。塑料不易老化，我们看不到这一点，是因为我们在看到它处于那个阶段之前就已经把它扔掉了。在未来，我们花了巨大力气让它们看起来充满爱意和穿旧感的牛仔裤，可能不会像李维斯档案馆里的那些牛仔裤那样老化。这就是人们需要意识到的：塑料有时会以这样一种方式老化，即它们试图恢复成气体，或者它们想要恢复成液体。这意味着，如果你觉得你穿了很长时间的运动鞋鞋底开始粘在地上了。你应该把它扔掉，因为它是我们所说的渗液或其他术语。它正在恢复其液态。它是剧毒的。
You don't want to touch it. Same with something if you keep a plastic comb or Home or Brett or a tupperware container. You never know in airtight drawers, how you don't open it for years. And then you open it and you find shards. It means that it exploded. It literally combusted at some point and you will smell it. These things are giving off noxious fumes.
你不会想去碰它。如果你把一个塑料梳子或家里的东西或面包或特百惠容器保存起来，也是如此。你永远不知道在气密抽屉里，你多年不打开它会怎么样。然后你打开它，发现碎屑。这意味着它爆炸了。它在某个时刻字面意义上燃烧了，你会闻到气味。这些东西正在散发出有害的气体。
And again, we don't tend to see this because we see plastic as disposable, but that's what this stuff is doing in these landfills. And the vast majority of clothes do end up in landfills. Even if you donate your clothes, you're mostly only delaying the inevitable. And again, this is not just genes. There are plastics and harmful dyes and damaging processes in a lot of our clothes. Denim isn't even the worst culprit. No, I mean, not more than necessarily any other play like leather is a
同样，我们往往看不到这一点，因为我们认为塑料是一次性的，但这就是这些东西在垃圾填埋场所做的事情。绝大多数衣服最终确实都进了垃圾填埋场。即使你捐赠了你的衣服，你大多也只是延迟了不可避免的结局。同样，这不仅限于牛仔裤。我们的许多衣服中都含有塑料、有害染料和破坏性的加工过程。丹宁甚至不是最糟糕的罪魁祸首。不，我的意思是，不一定比皮革等任何其他地方更严重，皮革是一个
industry with a whole lot of problems. Denim's just one because you know you can isolate it so easily. Denim is easily isolated from the rest of the clothing industry because it is so goddamn popular. On any given day, over half the population of the world is wearing jeans. So when you have numbers, consumption numbers like that coming from one faction of the industry, that's when this kind of environmental impact starts to become so significant. The average American owns seven pairs of jeans. Where these jeans are gonna end up,
存在着一大堆问题的行业。丹宁只是其中之一，因为你知道你可以很容易地把它孤立出来。丹宁很容易从其余的服装行业中分离出来，因为它是如此该死地受欢迎。在任何特定的一天，世界上有一半以上的人口都在穿着牛仔裤。所以当你有来自服装行业某一个阵营的消费数字时，这种环境影响才开始变得如此重大。美国人平均拥有七条牛仔裤。这些牛仔裤最终将去往何方，
what it took to create them is just staggering. It's also dizzying because in examining jeans, you realize that it's nearly impossible to create a morally perfect piece of clothing, at least one that's affordable. There's hypocrisy in everything we do. What do you mean? Well, you know, like let's take jeans, for instance, you say, okay, we're buying organic gene, and then you add petroleum
创造它们所付出的代价简直令人震惊。这也是令人眩晕的，因为在审视牛仔裤时，你会意识到，创造出一件道德上完美的衣服几乎是不可能的，至少是一件买得起的衣服。我们所做的一切都存在虚伪。你是什么意思？嗯，你知道的，比如我们以牛仔裤为例，你说，好吧，我们正在买有机牛仔裤，然后你加入了石油
base into go. So, denomakers have to pick and choose their priorities. Whether those priorities are local labor. Some people are all about local. Or natural fibers, not using pesticides or chemicals. Or comfort, or affordability, or trendinessiness. Obviously the ideal is that you're completely sustainable, that we're all buying organic local, whatever. But the reality out there in the world is that's very difficult or nearly impossible. So I think what people should do who are listening is that they should pick what's most important to them. And your dollar is the vote you cast. Edakong at Greenpeace says companies directly respond to our buying habits. They are Americans customers, actually have power on the brands.
基靛蓝。所以，丹宁制造商必须有所选择并权衡他们的优先事项。这些优先事项是当地劳动力。有些人全心全意关注本地。或者是天然纤维，不使用杀虫剂或化学品。或者是舒适度，或者是负担能力，或者是时尚度。显而易见的理想状态是你是完全可持续的，我们都在购买有机本地的等等。但世界上的现实是，这非常困难或几乎是不可能的。所以我认为正在听节目的大家应该做的是，选择对他们来说最重要的事情。你的金钱就是你投出的选票。绿色和平组织的孔蔼怡说，企业直接对我们的购买习惯做出反应。作为美国消费者，他们实际上对品牌拥有权力。
And the brands actually have power to influence the factory since the price in China. And this is what has been happening. Clothing manufacturers have been hearing a real consumer demand for sustainability. Well, we're very excited. Tracy Panek at Levi's says the company is working on this technology, where the genes will be worn in with lasers, rather than stonewashing and sanding. Using lasers to work on those finishes to cut down the time and all the chemicals that are used.
而品牌实际上有能力通过中国的产品价格来影响工厂。这就是正在发生的事情。服装制造商一直在听到消费者对可持续发展的真正需求。好吧，我们非常兴奋。李维斯（Levi's）的特蕾西·帕尼克（Tracy Panek）表示，该公司正在开发这样一种技术，即通过激光而不是石洗和打磨来让牛仔裤呈现旧感。使用激光来处理这些饰面，以减少时间和所有使用的化学品。
We have been working on ways to reduce the amount of water needed to create a pair of blue jeans. And we've not only done that in our processing the way we manufacture, saving water, but also in sharing the message that you don't have to wash your blue jeans as much. And it's true. You don't have to wash your jeans as much. Really you can wash them every fifth-where or so, and you can patch them and stain them and wear them and tear them more than you can with other clothes. On the user end, within our closets, high quality genes are a very sustainable garment,
我们一直在研究如何减少制作一条蓝色牛仔裤所需的水量。我们不仅在加工制造方式上做到了这一点，节约了用水，而且还在传播这样一种信息：你不需要把你的蓝色牛仔裤洗得那么勤。这是真的。你不需要把牛仔裤洗得那么勤。真的，你大概穿五次左右洗一次就行了，你可以给它们打补丁、弄上污渍，而且你可以比其他衣服更多地穿着和撕裂它们。在消费者端，在我们的衣橱里，高质量的牛仔裤是一件非常可持续的服装，
as long as we don't throw them away. What everybody should just do is stop buying as much. The crux of the issue is that we should learn how to keep our clothing, think of clothing as something to have and to mend, don't automatically get rid of something. And if you do keep them around long enough, and really let them walk through your life with you, your genes will start to express how you move through the world. Our pants and our clothing will continue to tell aspects about ourselves based on how they've worn.
只要我们不把它们扔掉。每个人应该做的就是停止买那么多。问题的核心在于，我们应该学会如何保留我们的衣服，把衣服看作是拥有和缝补的东西，不要自动扔掉某样东西。如果你确实把它们留得够久，并且真正让它们陪着你走过你的生活，你的牛仔裤就会开始表达你是如何在这个世界中穿行的。我们的裤子和我们的衣服将继续根据它们的磨损程度来讲述关于我们自己的方方面面。
Arguably blue jeans should be a thing of the past. But in modern times, without real cotton or real indigo or real years of hard labor wearing them in, we still want our jeans to look the same as they did in 1879. So in all these hidden ways, jeans have changed in accordance with society want our genes to look the same as they did in 1879. So in all these hidden ways, genes have changed in accordance with society, in the ways they're made, and how they're worn, and they will continue to evolve,
可以说，蓝色牛仔裤应该成为过去式。但在现代，没有真正的棉花、没有真正的靛蓝、没有真正多年的苦力将它们穿旧，我们仍然希望我们的牛仔裤看起来和1879年一模一样。所以，通过所有这些隐藏的方式，牛仔裤一直在随着社会的发展而改变，我们希望我们的牛仔裤看起来和1879年一模一样。所以，通过所有这些隐藏的方式，牛仔裤一直在随着社会的发展而改变，包括它们的制造方式和穿着方式，并且它们将继续演变，
even if they continue to appear unchanged. The pocket, the piece of paper Words from yesterday There's a portrait painted on the things we love We love. Articles of Interest is made by myself, Avery Treffleman, with editing from Emmett Fitzgerald and Joe Rosenberg, music by Ray Royal, intro and outro themes by Sassalmi Ashworth. Fact check by Graham Haysha, Mix by Kelly Coin, and Roman Mars is the ethical manufacturer of this whole series. Special thanks to Aaron Newport, Brad Bunn, Taylor Hamilton, Morgan Brown, Sally Fox, and
即使它们看起来依然没有改变。口袋，一张纸，来自过去的字句。在我们喜爱的事物上描绘着一幅肖像。我们所爱的事物。《感兴趣的物件》由我自己——艾瑞里·特雷夫曼（Avery Truffleman）制作，由埃姆·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）和乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）剪辑，雷·皇家（Ray Royal）配乐，片头和片尾曲由萨萨尔米·阿什沃思（Sassalmi Ashworth）创作。格雷厄姆·海沙（Graham Haysha）负责事实核查，凯利·科恩（Kelly Coin）负责混音，罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）是整个系列的道德制造商。特别感谢阿伦·纽帕特（Aaron Newport）、布拉德·邦恩（Brad Bunn）、泰勒·汉密尔顿（Taylor Hamilton）、摩根·布朗（Morgan Brown）、莎莉·福克斯（Sally Fox）和
Elaine Hamblin, as well as Katie Mingle, Delaney Hall, Vivian Lee, Sean Reale, Shereef There's a portrait of painting on the things we love. The fashion industry is very terrible for the environment. The textile industry now accounts for more greenhouse gas emissions than all international flights and maritime shipping combined. So you might be thinking, okay, wow, fashion is the worst. We are all slaves to desire and capitalism and the endless cycle of trends and it's so vain and time consuming and killing the planet.
伊莱恩·汉布林（Elaine Hamblin），以及凯蒂·明格尔（Katie Mingle）、德兰尼·霍尔（Delaney Hall）、薇薇安·李（Vivian Lee）、肖恩·里尔（Sean Reale）、谢里夫。在我们喜爱的事物上有一幅肖像画。时尚产业对环境极其糟糕。纺织工业现在造成的温室气体排放量超过了所有国际航班和海上运输的总和。所以你可能会想，好吧，哇，时尚是最糟糕的。我们都是欲望、资本主义和无休止的潮流循环的奴隶，它是如此虚荣、耗时并正在杀死地球。
So I'm just going to get one high quality uniform and wear it every single day forever, just like Steve Jobs or Mark Zuckerberg. I wear the gray shirt when I'm going to work or during the weekday and the ideas I don't want to really have to spend much time thinking about what I'm wearing, but for the weekends I figure you know gotta have some fun. So I actually have the same shirt in other colors and I wear those on the weekend. This is kind of the central question of it all.
所以我打算只买一套高质量的制服，然后永远天天穿它，就像史蒂夫·乔布斯（Steve Jobs）或马克·扎克伯格（Mark Zuckerberg）一样。我去上班或工作日的时候穿灰色的衬衫，我的想法是我不想花太多时间去考虑我穿什么，但对于周末，我想你知道的，得有点乐子。所以我实际上有其他颜色的同款衬衫，我在周末穿那些。这可以说是这一切的核心问题。
Like why bother? Why bother dressing up or dressing differently? Your next article of interest is punk. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
就像为什么还要费事呢？为什么要费事盛装打扮或穿得与众不同呢？你的下一件感兴趣的物件是朋克。来自PRX。这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子来留下评论。